on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander of logan webb webb 24
years old out of rocklin california it's
in the second year at the big league
level six one 215 pounder it's the thing
about logan webb is that he has such
good stuff at times he can tell you what
is coming and you still can't hit it
runner goes
posey's got it his throw
perfect wow
i mean if it's
six inches higher he's safe i mean all
longoria does here is just catch the
ball
and just right there
is hamson who slides right into it with
nowhere to go it absolutely had to be
perfect but they had no chance that's
the first time this year that hamson has
been thrown out 2-2 now on mcmahon
caught out here on left side to find a
hole just like he said cory and there's
ryan mcmahon with the base hit great job
of hitting by ryan mcmahon recognizing
that backdoor slider i think it was
and just
taking it to left field not trying to do
too much not trying to drive the ball
the bottom half as chi-chi gonzalez
makes his first start of the year tommy
stella gets a start he will lead it off
stella goes the other way for a base hit
he hit that just like you're supposed to
what a great attack cutter away and the
stella leaned over the plate a lead off
single for the giants it's nothing
nothing cj crone is going to hit quick
02.
three pitches see you later first
strikeout this o2 pitch with the seconds
lottery drops down just a little bit
with his arm angle it flattens out the
break throws it on the outside corner
let the movement fall out of the zone
and hope he chases and it's exactly what
crone did
on the ground to longoria
steps on the bag
broken back ground ball by diaz and
longoria was perfectly placed to turn it
into an inning ending double play so
that's huge webb is off the mound no
score as we move into inning number two
oh two swing and a miss he got him with
a slider first strike out of the day for
a gt here's chi-chi gonzalez got him
second strikeout down and away and here
comes hampson
he delivers
popped up
it'll either be le stella
and it's lestella who at the last second
puts it away
and given
how that play was made i think your
strepski is thinking i'm going to call
the next one
yeah
i think la stella would agree with that
as well this is not easy southern
california and uh pop-ups are adventures
and this thing just sort of drifts and
he uses every bit of this glove right
there at the end of his pocket in his
web
one-two pitch
strike three caught in the outside
corner with a fastball we go to the
giants half of the third top of the
order for the giants in a nothing
nothing ball game
drives this one into right center field
blackman on the move and he can't get it
hamson
picks it up on a bounce and le stella's
got a double boy he tomahawked that he
taught my hockey because it was right up
there across the letters maybe even
higher they
shaded him over in the left center field
side and they gave the gap in right
center this ball right up there
above the letters and there's your
tomahawk
and he finds a slot in the defense where
nobody can get to it just like that a
lead-off double they got a runner in
scoring position so here's the stremski
nobody outrunner at second base
pulled hard smothered by crone and he
got it just off the dirt snaring that
line drive chichi gonzalez with a glove
point over to cj krohn who's picked two
off the
infield dirt yeah he did it to the guy
coming to the plate now alex dickerson
dickerson slightly open stance feet
fairly close together deep in the box
crowding the plate
little flare
and it's going to fall
and they're going to wave in lestella
and
well they call that baseball dickerson
in his last at bat with our quarters at
first and second hit up p rod
got caught here
he gets a jam sandwich he throws out
just over the head
of fuentes at third
and
that's an rbi single top of the fourth
inning 2-0 pitch
driven towards center field this will
get over dubai 2-0 pitch that charlie
golfs out into the middle of fairway in
san francisco charlie blackman letting
this ball travel
lets it get deep driving into the left
center where they're overshifting into
right center you see dubon get back on
it get to see charlie
stay through that baseball so well
that's the approach you have to have
when a guy settled in with his off speed
pitches lots of boos for rymel tapia i'm
assuming the call coming from left field
is hit towards center field it's gonna
fall
and so topia two for two on the day
charlie blackman will score
we have a tie game in san francisco do
you think rymel is yelling back at
little f fans right now who's the bum
now the bum now he's putting bat to ball
and making things happen elias diaz on
two
fastball
one away boy that absolutely bow walked
diaz i mean that's a back door sinker
perfectly placed in the outside corner
he gave up on that pitch and the
movement brought it back into the strike
zone for a strikeout for logan webb
logan webb still only 24 years old from
rocklin up near sacramento
strikes recall
throws big time sync with big time
movement on the inside corner strikeout
number five mcmahon 2-2
oh that balls
sky towards right center field did he
get enough
he did
bye felicia boom roasted
ryan mcmahon with his
fifth home run at 20 21 a two run shot
in the rockies lead three to one i love
the approach by mac right there
that was absolutely sky and it was
roasted story is second blackman still
runs well he's at first
and he struck it out a foul tip into
posey's glow now the giants have to play
catch up there goes the runner
buster's throw right there he's out
i didn't think buster posey had a chance
tina berger's unboat time was right at
1.50
that is slow
yet comes up very economical footwork
and an absolute dart to la stella
that slaps it on him
buster posey has made through two throws
today he got hansen in the first and now
he gets topia and i don't know how you
could be any better
3-2
deep
right field
it sounds like 40 000 are back in town
at oracle park
brandon crawford
has electrified this ballpark
a three-run laser beam
three the giants are on top
odam worked himself into it get it in
situation
and crawford who had a great 3-1 swing
with great balance does it again in a
3-2 count and knocks it right out of
here
for the town of the seventh inning four
three giants pitcher now for the giants
will be arreyos moronta the fourth time
that he has come in close three and two
got him fastball
fastball to 93 miles an hour almost
looks like you had a little cut to it at
the last two down and here is mcmahon
the pitch
got him two strikeouts in the seventh
for maranta he's got the thick of the
lineup now
there's longo spins fuentes from his
knees wow
wow how did he do that
cannot wait to see the replay because we
haven't we can't we didn't see it just
like you guys didn't i'm excited
oh what a play the transition that was
incredible oh look at the footwork
there's no footwork that's straight pure
defense
wow josh fuentes with an unbelievable
play robbie longoria the biggest hit so
three and two to diaz got him
persistence with the fastball
the high target right above the hands
and he sends it back to the dugout 95 so
alatrejo the new
hitter making his major league debut
center field
ballgame
well it was a three-run home run there
was a difference in this game and they
win the ball game final score giants
four rockies three